the National Health Service in England  has announced 10 further deaths of  patients who tested positive for  coronavirus so we had 11 deaths reported  with one in Scotland yesterday and that  is the latest line from National Health  Service in England that 10 further  deaths of patients who tested positive  before coronavirus Ashish Joshi our  health correspondent is here I see that  those are extraordinary figures it's  Sunday it's a doubling of the figures we  have 11 people who have been reported  dead from coronavirus yesterday if what  we're hearing from Professor Chris Witte  the chief medical officer confirm attend  further patients of tested positive have  died that would be 21 people that I mean  we just haven't had that sort of figure  in the UK before we've had we've had  single deaths and then that went to  double deaths and we were told to expect  the numbers to rise but we just haven't  seen a doubling in the number of people  who have actually died before  you